we'll often talk on the show
about how on so many different issues
the country meaning the voters
are as far left as they have been
often times for as long as we've been
keeping track of certain metrics so as
an example we'll often say well when you
ask people should abortion be legal in
most cases
we have more approval for that yes
abortion should be legal in most cases
today than at any point during the
roe v wade era which started decades and
decades ago we talk about gay marriage
for example we'll talk about well should
the government provide some basic level
of health care to everybody regardless
of ability to pay
but another area in which public opinion
has shifted towards the left over the
last many years that does not get as
much attention is support for labor
unions labor unions in the united states
are experiencing based on this brand new
gallup poll
that came out
under two weeks ago which i did not talk
about but i'm talking about today
approval for labor unions in the united
states is at its highest point since
1965. that's 57 years
and uh when you look at the numbers you
now see that 68 percent of americans
currently approve of labor unions that's
a number that bottomed out at 48 in 2009
that got close to 68
in the late 90s and early 2000s but you
have actually have to go all the way
back to 1965
where you see that support for labor
unions was at 71 now this is data that
we have going back a long way because
gallup has measured this support for
labor unions going all the way back to
1936 and there was a period in the
united states from 36 to 67 roughly
where if you're looking at this uh chart
you see this graph
you see that there was just generally
higher support in that roughly 30-year
period you had an average of 68 support
for labor unions in the united states
that dropped into the mid to high 50s
for a while and went even lower around
the time of the great recession but
those numbers have now recovered and the
interesting question would be why
one part of this is when you break down
these numbers by party affiliation
democrats republicans independents it
won't shock you that support among
democrats is where labor union support
is highest but even among democrats
labor union support has also hit a
20-year high labor union support among
democrats has always been higher in this
entire period but it is particularly
higher right now as well and to
understand what's going on you need only
look at sort of the world around us in
the united states
people are increasingly understanding
that we need some counter-balancing
power or influence
against the power of corporations and
against the power of employers in the
employee employer relationship
this is a reaction to what is correctly
being seen out in the world
uh the gig economy
more and more people realizing how
absurd the disconnect between
productivity and wages has become even
if you don't know that technically even
if you don't have the data in front of
you
intuitively there is a sense of that
and it is true that on some of these
things the pendulum sort of switch
swings back and forth and there are
periods where the country moves away
from favoring labor unions to some
degree and moves back in favor of labor
unions the key
is what can you get done when the
pendulum is swinging in your favor what
can you accomplish when support is
higher
i think it also should be mentioned
that president joe biden is arguably
more pro-union vocally so
than any recent president i mean
certainly in the last 20 or so years
and he talks about it as well and joe
biden's background uh riding the the
amtrak train amtrak also has been in the
news for what appears to be a narrowly
averted major work stoppage uh labor
strike uh biden talks about that
certainly more than trump
more than obama of course more than bush
and i i guess you have to go back and
think well is it sort of like a clinton
level amount of talking about labor
unions so none of this should shock us
the optimistic thing is
we often worry and i talk about this on
the show all the time
that there's a disconnect
between
what is happening in the country
and public opinion so for example you
will see the republican party
swing
cartoonishly and absurdly into this maga
world where there is no more policy
it's
authoritarianism and sort of fascistic
dictatorial wet dreaming in terms of
what they would like to see
while claiming to be about small
government what it just doesn't make any
sense and we sometimes see that the
republican party electorate or just
voters in general they don't see the
scope of what is happening within the
republican party and this ends up with
you know herschel walker might defeat
rafael warnock in georgia and it's
horrible in other words we often are
concerned that the people are not
reacting to the reality of what's going
on
the good news here
if we want to find some good news beyond
just oh it's good that people are
more in favor of labor unions
is that
this is an accurate and logical reaction
to what is happening uh in terms of the
relationships between employer and
employee in terms of the
disproportionate power that large
corporations have not only with regard
to their employees but also with regard
to taxation and so many other things so
this is good to see the question now
becomes what's going to be done about it
will there actually be any steps in
terms of the democratization of work joe
biden has ideas that are going nowhere
naturally because of uh what's going on
in the senate right now and not having
60 votes but we're going to continue
talking about it and the first step in
achieving change is public opinion
uniting and we're seeing that to some
degree
the david pakman show's longest running
sponsor is blinkist the app that takes
thousands of non-fiction books boils
each of them down into an explainer you
can read or listen to in 15 minutes
blinkist also condenses episodes of
popular podcasts into 15-minute
explainers i've been using blinkist for
years to supplement the books i read i
love reading i i read all the time
but there's even more books i don't have
time to read and you can often find
those non-fiction books on blinkist and
consume the entire thing in 15 minutes
my favorite new feature on the app is
blinkist connect which lets you share
your blinkist premium account with
someone else you basically get two
accounts for the price of one and then
you can also share blinkist books and
podcasts between users i have a joint
blinkist premium account with my
girlfriend blinkist connect lets us sync
together what books and podcasts we're
listening to on blinkist sparks many
interesting discussions we just listened
to robert greene's the 48 laws of power
the new version robert greene super
interesting writer find his books
fascinating you can try blinkist free
for seven days and get 25 off a premium
subscription at blinkist.com david
pakman the link is down below